>>> WE'LL BREAK IT DOWN SLOWLY.
A BIG HOUR TONIGHT, THE
CONSTRUCT TRUMP HATING NEWS
MEDIA IS DUSTING OFF THE TIN
FOIL HATS AND FUELLING UP THEIR
BLACK HELICOPTERS AND RUNNING
WILD WITH BASELESS CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS IS NOW INSANE.
THIS IS A NEW LEVEL OF BIAS.
DR. RONNY JACKSON BRIEFED THE
MEDIA ON THE EXAM HE FOUND A
PRESIDENT IN EXCELLENT WELL AND
DID SO WELL IN A COGNITIVE TASK
AND HAS PERFECT NEUROLOGICAL
FUNCTIONS.
NO EARLY ONSET ALZHEIMER'S OR
DEMENTIA.
THIS DOES NOT FIT THE NARRATIVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CRAZY
SUFFERING FROM DEMENTIA AND
MENTALLY UNFIT TO SERVE.
WHICH MEANS IN THEIR TWISTED
MINDS HE NEEDS TO BE KIKSD
MINDS HE NEEDS TO BE KIKS
MINDS HE NEEDS TO BE KICK
MINDS HE NEEDS TO BE KICKED
MINDS HE NEEDS TO BE KICKED O
MINDS HE NEEDS TO BE KICKED OUT
OF OFFICE THE MEDIA ASKED ABOUT
THE COGNITIVE TEST IS ONE OF THE
BEST THROUGHOUT AND PASSED IT
PERFECTLY, 30 OUT OF 30.
YOU'LL ENJOY THIS, WATCH.
>> Reporter: CAN YOU ADDRESS THE
PRESIDENT'S FITNESS?
HE SLURRED HIS WORDS DURING THE
DRESS.
DID YOU LOOK INTO THE CAUSE?
DID YOU RULE OUT EARLY ONSET
ALZHEIMER'S OR DEMENTIA.
>> THIS SAY PHILOSOPHICAL
QUESTION, WOULD YOU ADVISE THE
CABINET THE PRESIDENT SUN ABLE
TO DISCHARGE HIS DUTIES?
GAVE THE PRESIDENT A COGNITIVE
TEST, CAN YOU TELL US WHAT
SPECIFIC COGNITIVE TEST HE WAS
GIVEN WHERE THERE'S SCRUTINY OF
WHAT WAS OVERLOOKED FROM
PRESIDENT REAGAN WAS KNOWN TO
SUFFER FROM AT A LATER DATE.
WOULD THE TEST YOU RAN EXCLUDE
ANY OF THOSE THINGS.
>> WITH HIS AGE AND IN
CONTINUING PHYSICALS WILL YOU
CONTINUE THE COGNITIVE TESTING.
>> YOU SAID THE PRESIDENT
REQUESTED THE COGNITIVE TEST AND
WANTED IT DONE?
>> Reporter: WHAT IS YOUR TAKE
FOR THOSE WHO SAID THEY SEE
>> SYMPTOMS LIKE?
>> Reporter: DEMENTIA.
>> TO REITERATE, DR. JACKSON
TOLD THE MEDIA THE PRESIDENT IS
IN EXCELLENT HEALTH AND COULD
SERVE FOR TWO TERMS.
HE HAS MODERATELY HIGH
POUNDS.
GOOD NEWS OR BELIEVE IT.
THEY HAVE SO CONVINCED
THEMSELVES AND THE ECHO CHAMBER
ONLY THEY LISTEN TO AND
SPECULATION THE PRESIDENT WAS
UNFIT FOR OFFICE.
THE PRESIDENT CONFERENCE JUST
CONTINUED TO GO OFF THE RAILS
LIKE I HAVE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
MEDIA ASKING DR. JACKSON ABOUT
THINGS LIKE THE PRESIDENT'S
TWITTER USE, HIS TELEVISION
WATCHING HABITS, HOW MANY SCOOPS
OF ICE CREAM HE HAS FOR DESSERT.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
IS "SUPPOSEDLY" INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALISM IN ACTION IN THIS
COUNTRY.
IN HOW MUCH GOLF THE
U.S. PRESIDENT PLAYS?
>> Reporter: SOME THINK HE'S
BEHAVIOR?
>> Reporter: DO YOU SEE EVIDENCE
OF BONE SPURS?
>> TWITTER DOESN'T CONCERN ME AS
A DOCK FOR.
>> Reporter: DOES THE WEAR
DENTURES.
>> HE DOESN'T WEAR ANY OF ANY
KIND.
>> Reporter: YOU SAID HE DOESN'T
DRINK OR SMOKE, DID YOU ADDRESS
>> Reporter: ANY OTHER DRUGS?
>> NO, HE HAS NO DRUG ADDICTION.
>> WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THE STUDIO ALL LAUGHING.
WE WENT BACK AND CHECKED TO SEE
IF THE MEDIA EVER ASKED ANYTHING
CLOSE TO THOSE KINDS OF
MATTER AND THE ANSWER, THEY DID
NOT.
AFTER THE FRENZY, MEMBERS OF THE
MEDIA SHOULD HAVE THEIR OWN
HEADS EXAMINED.
HATING TRUMP IS THEIR HEROIN,
THEY'RE DRUG.
THEY'RE LIKE ADDICTS.
THE ONLY THING THAT GIVES THEM
THEIR FIX IS ATTACKING THE
PRESIDENT MINUTE BY MINUTE AND
THE MEDIA IS SO COMPLETELY
UTTERLY UNHINGED AND DERANGED
AND TODAY'S PRESIDENT CONFERENCE
IS THE LATEST EPISODE.
EVER SINCE PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED HIS CANDIDACY YOU HAVE
THE MEDIA WITH THEIR OWN TALKING
POINTS AND ECHO CHAMBER HAVE
BEEN RUSHING TO CREATE A NEW
CRISIS ANOTHER CRISIS AND THE
HYPER VENTILATION HAS REACHED
EXTREME LEVELS EVEN BY THEIR LOW
STANDARDS, BY THE WAY.
IT'S ONE TOTAL MELTDOWN AFTER
ANOTHER WHERE THEY REPEAT THE
SAME WORDS MEANING ABC, NBC, NEW
YORK TIMES, WASHINGTON POST.
THEY USE THE SAME COMMENTARY
UNTIL SOMETHING BETTER CAN COME
ALONG.
THE SCHIZOPHRENIA HAS GONE FROM
A YEAR OF SAYING PRESIDENT TRUMP
INCLUDED WITH RUSSIANS TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL START A
NUCLEAR WAR.
THEY'RE NOT CONCERNED PRESIDENT
WERE FRIENDS FOR THREE DAYS AND
THEY LIKED HIS COMMENTS FOR ONCE
AND THE NARRATIVE IS NOW TRUMP'S
CRAZY.
WE SHOULD INVOKE THE 25th
LOOK AT THE INSANE COVERAGE
YOU'RE GETTING AND I TELL YOU
MEDIA'S DEAD.
DREAMED.
WEEK IN RUSSIA GATE.
>> THE CLOUD WILL HANG OVER HIM
NO MATTER WHERE HE STANDS.
>> A POLITICAL HURRICANE IS OUT
AT SEA FOR HIM WE'LL CALL IT
HURRICANE VLADIMIR.
>> IT'S WILLINGNESS TO COMMIT
TREESON.
>> HE'S GIVINGED A -- AITD AND
COME
AID AND COMFORT TO THE ENEMY.
>> I RECOMMEND DELETING YOUR
TWITTER APP.
>> THIS IS SCRIPT FROM DR.
STRANGELOVE.
WE CAN'T BEGIN TO NORMALIZE
THIS.
THIS IS CHILDISH AND NOT
BEFITTING OF A FREE LEADER OF
THE WORLD.
>> NOWHERE HAVE WE SEEN HISSIN
SECURITIES THREATENING STO  --
TO ANNIHILATE THE PLANET.
>> HE'S BEING CAVALIER IN A WAY
THAT MAKES HIM SEEM DEMENT.
>> THE PUBLIC RIFF BROKE OUT
BETWEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
FORMER FRIEND, STEVE BANNON.
WALLACE.
IF YOU WATCH CLOSELY, THIS IS
INTERESTING.
ONE PERSON WILL SAY IN THEIR
BUBBLE, HE'S DEMENTED.
NO, HE'S REALLY, REALLY,
DEMENTED.
THEN THE NEXT LIBERAL SAYS NO,
REALLY, REALLY, DEMENTED.
AFTER MOVING ON FROM ONE
MANUFACTURED CRISIS AFTER
CNN NEEDS HELP.
ACCORDING TO THE MEDIA RESEARCH
CENTER THE NETWORK SAID ON
TIMES ON FRIDAY ALONE.
TAKE A LOOK.
AFRICAN NATIONS [BLEEP] HOLES.
>> IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT HE MEANT.
>> I'M NOT PROUD.
>> WE'RE NOT ALL CREATED EQUAL
IF YOU WERE, AS THE PRESIDENT
PUT IT A [BLEEP] HOLE COUNTRY.
THE WORSE HOUSE INSTEAD OF HOLE.
IS THERE A DIFFERENCE IF THE
PRESIDENT SAID HOLE OR HOUSE?
>> DO YOU THINK THE COUNTRIES
ARE [BLEEP] HOLES.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS TURNED THE
>> HOLE.
[BLEEP] HOLE COUNTRY THAT IS
PREDOMINANTLY CAUCASIAN?
>> [BLEEP] HOLE.
>> I'M PROUD TO BE A [BLEEP]
HOLER.
>> THAT'S ALL FAKE NEWS NETWORK.
I WONDER IF THE CEO -- SOON TO
BE SCANDAL-PLAGUED OWNER IS
PROUD OF THAT COVERAGE.
IT'S PATHETIC.
MAYBE I NEED TO DO A PUBLIC
SERVICE.
MAYBE I NEED TO SEND CNN A CASE
OF XANAX, IF I CAN GET IT
LEGALLY AND SINCE THEY'RE LED BY
BERZINSKI AND LOVE TO PLAY THE
GAME AND I'LL STEP IN THEIR ECHO
CHAMBER.
HERE'S DR. HANNITY'S
REDESCRIPTION TONIGHT, ALL OF
YOU IN THE FAKE NEWS NETWORK,
REALITY AND SUFFER FROM
DELUSIONAL GROUP THINK ABOUT THE
JOURNALISTS
JOURNALIST
JOURNALISTS CAN'T PAY FOR IT
I'LL OFFER ASSISTANCE.
EVERYTHING IS PLAYING OUT.
THIS IS THE SERIOUS SIDE.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT FORGOTTEN
MEN AND WOMEN -- AND THIS ISN'T
ABOUT ME OR THE SHOW BE RIGHT
THOUGH THE TEAM WE ASUM --
ASSEMBLED HERE, IT'S ABOUT
WHAT'S RIGHT FOR THE COUNTRY AND
RULE OF LAW AND EQUAL JUSTICE OF
THE LAW.
WE HAVE BEEN UNCOVERING AND
UNPEELING THE LAYERS OF THAT
ONION.
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION AND THE
RUSSIAN DOSIER AND WE'RE
LEARNING IT WAS USED BY THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND SPY AND
GET THE FISA WARRANT AGAINST THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THEY WEAPONIZED THE TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE TO GO AFTER A PARTY
IN AN ELECTION YEAR AND THEN
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
WE HAVE A MASSIVE DEVELOPMENT IN
THE CLINTON E-MAIL SCANDAL.
CLINTON E-MAIL INVESTIGATION.
OH, I THOUGHT THAT WAS BET AND
RABIKI IS ONE JAMES COMY SENT AN
EXONERATION FOR BEFORE THERE WAS
AN INVESTIGATION.
FROM GROSS NEGLIGENCE WHICH
HIS MINIONS ALTERED THE
CONCLUSION.
IT'S REASONABLE THAT THE CLINTON
SERVER WAS HACKED AND SPECIAL
PROGRAM INFORMATION ALL HACKED
AND THE FIX IS IN BEFORE THEY
INVESTIGATE AND NOW WE'RE
LEARNING MORE AND MORE HOW THE
TOP OFFICIALS AT THE FBI COVERED
UP HILLARY CLINTON COMMITTED
CRIMES AND PUT OUR NATIONAL,
YOUR NATIONAL SECURITY AT RISK.
LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE WE TELL YOU
THE MEDIA IGNORES IT'S THE START
OF MUCH BIGGER THINGS THAT WILL
BE COMING.
I PROMISE IT WILL RIVAL THE
WORST SCANDAL.
AND SARA CARTER REPORTING THE
BIG NEWS, RUSSIAN DOSSIER AND WE
KNOW HILLARY CLINTON FUNDED
FUSION GPS TO PAY FOR THE
RUSSIAN LIES AND THEY WANTED TO
INFLUENCE THE ELECTION THEY
STOLE THE PRIMARY FROM POOR
BERNIE AND SOURCES ARE TELLING
ME IF THE INFORMATION IS ABOUT
THE DOSSIER RELATE TO THE PUBIC,
HERE'S WHAT I'M TOLD, IT WILL
SHOCK THE CONSCIOUS OF
PEOPLE, YOU'LL GET TO SEE
EVERYTHING BECAUSE I'M TOLD WHEN